tous les ingrédients étaient rassemblées
par le fc versailles pour faire une
bonne rentrée dans le championnat
national une victoire 2 1 au bout du
suspense grâce à ce but de la recrue
monde dit prunier à la 94ème minute le
stade jean bouin du stade français paris
en toile de fond avec 3000 spectateurs
venus supporter les versailles et un
premier match idéal commencé cette
saison avec une victoire à domicile
avec ce public dans ces conditions on
est heureux et on espère justement
permettre à ce que d'autres matches à
domicile puis ça va encore encore plus
de supporters et de spectateurs et qu'on
puisse susciter la curiosité en sus de
réussir à fidéliser les personnes les
gens ont fait l'effort justement de
venir nous voir aujourd'hui nombreux
hélas la moindre des choses c'était de
leur montrer dans notre comportement
dans notre attitude qu'on pouvait avoir
collectivement sur le terrain de leur
donner envie de s'attacher à nous
justement à être revenir dans une
rencontre très disputée face à martigues
le fc versailles a ouvert le score à la
20e minute
les provençaux répondent sept minutes
plus tard en transformant un penalty
suite à une faute versaillaise mais les
yvelinois n'ont rien lâché jusqu'à être
libéré avec ses premières victoires
versailles occupe la quatrième place au
classement
l'objectif numéro un du club ses c'est
de se maintenir c'est quand même une
année très particulière avec le nombre
de descentes jamais jamais vu dans cette
division donc
ça va être une bataille tous les
week-ends à la fin de cette saison de
national six clubs seront relégués sur
les 18 présents dans ce championnat la
bataille est donc lancé de la meilleure
des manières pour les versaillais
prochaine rencontre au puy-en-velay
vendredi 19 août